So up to now,
we have built a univariate kernel density estimator, which gives us our model.
Now we ask the question, is the model optimal?
We discussed the bandwidth and
how that plays a role in determining the quality of our model.
To validate our model, we will need some validation techniques for
estimating probability density.
One way to do this is to minimize the MISE, or the AMISE.
The MISE stands for the mean integrated standard error.
And the AMISE stands for asymptotic limit of the mean integrated standard error.
We can also minimise the KL Divergence,
which is called the Kulberk-Liebler divergence.
We're, we're going to look into some of these validation techniques and
derive some rules of thumb of how to get an optimal bandwidth.